There are plenty of big secrets at the SCP
Foundation, but sometimes, you’ve just gotta
wonder: What are the smaller secrets?
Here at SCP Explained, we often zoom out to
give you a bird’s eye view of the bizarre
and sometimes inexplicable events concerning
a huge number of anomalies.
But today, we’re ditching our telescope
in favor of a microscope, to take a look into
the daily life of one very special blobby
boy: SCP-999, the Tickle Monster.
We took the liberty of painstakingly stalking
-er, uh, I mean, observing SCP-999 going about
his daily life, bringing joy to everyone around
him.
And not only were our otherwise cold, dead
hearts thoroughly warmed, we were also able
to compile everything we needed to make the
video you’re watching right now.
Welcome, one and all, to a Day In The Life
of SCP-999.
6:30 AM.
Rise and shine, happy campers!
We discovered that the Tickle Monster likes
to start his day nice and early.
After all, the more daylight you have out
there, the easier it is to put the sunshine
in people’s hearts.
So shortly after waking up, SCP-999 uses his
little blobby pseudopods to put on some pleasant
easy-listening music in his containment chamber.
Delightful.
He then drinks a glass of delicious soy milk
and helps himself to a balanced breakfast
of chocolate, M&Ms, and a variety of tasty
fruit-flavored gummies.
Please note: This is NOT an acceptable balanced
breakfast for human beings, it’s important
to remember that SCP-999 has very different
dietary needs to us humans.
Believe me, I tried the SCP-999 diet, all
I got was severe sugar headaches and overtime
on the toilet.
But the less said about that, the better.
After eating his delicious sugary breakfast,
the Tickle monster grabs a crayon and starts
building his day plan, which is normally filled
with a wide array of stimulating activities.
Every day is a new journey into excitement
for SCP-999.
This is part of SCP-999’s schedule that
we very much recommend you emulate.
Setting your goals nice and early may help
you solidify your goals nice and early, and
also help you feel a warm and fuzzy sense
of accomplishment when the day ends and all
your errands are complete.
But by the time all this is done for SCP-999,
it’s already…
8:00 AM.
Of course, while setting goals for the day
ahead is an important task, SCP-999, in its
surprisingly applicable wisdom, also knows
the power of inspiration.
That’s why, at around 8:00 AM, the Tickle
Monster indulges in his morning entertainment
before any tasks or cross-tests begin.
This largely involves watching cartoons on
a television set provided to him by his handlers
at the SCP Foundation.
SCP-999’s favorite shows include Spongebob
Squarepants, Blue’s Clues, and The Backyardigans.
The Foundation is extremely careful with the
programming that SCP-999 is allowed to indulge
in, making sure that all of the shows are
generally wholesome and sweet, with positive
moral messages that one can carry forward
into their day.
Spongebob is a particular favorite for that
exact reason - The Tickle Monster sees that
plucky yellow sponge as a kind of kindred
spirit, reminding him to keep a positive,
can-do attitude and a sense of childlike fun.
After a few episodes of the show, 999 is typically
bouncing with joy, and more than feeling Spongebob’s
iconic catchphrase - “I’m ready!”
And while it isn’t necessarily relevant,
we’d also like to state that within the
confines of this metaphor, Doctor Gears is
Squidward.
Moving on.
10:00 AM.
Now the Tickle Monster is really ready to
take on the day!
Having filled up on the two essential Cs of
any prosperous day - Candy and Cartoons - he’s
ready to slither out there and make a difference.
His first order of business for the work day
is sitting in on the daily Site-19 Senior
Researcher meeting, where the top brass of
the site is given a collective debrief on
the day’s tasks, and given an opportunity
to share any vital information.
Of course, morning meetings can be stressful,
especially when you work at the SCP Foundation,
where your daily task might be, “SCP-682
seems particularly cantankerous today, mind
paying a visit to his containment chamber
and asking him about it?”
However, SCP-999 being there in the room is
kind of like having the ultimate scented candle.
He exudes those chill, relaxing vibes, and
even the pleasant smell, that puts you in
a place of profound ease.
The Foundation has discovered that since SCP-999
has started sitting in on the morning meetings,
both employee satisfaction and task completion
have increased.
Happy workers, as it turns out, are also hard
workers.
When the meetings end and the senior researchers
are filing out of the room, each one of them
gives SCP-999 a little hug or a pat in hopes
of thanking him for all he does.
This increases their emotional well-being
as well as SCP-999’s.
It’s one of the rare “everyone wins”
scenarios you’ll find at the SCP Foundation.
After the meeting, SCP-999 tends to roam around
the site for a while, searching for anyone
in need.
As you probably already know, the Tickle Monster
has an innate sense for when people are in
need of his unique brand of anomalous positivity.
If a researcher or a guard is feeling down,
SCP-999 will have an innate sense of their
presence, and mercilessly hunt them down to
give them some pep they’ll never forget.
Allow us to give you a specific example: Security
Officer Dan Richardson was stressed.
While he didn’t let on to anyone else working
at the Foundation, fearing that showing emotion
would make people think less of him, his wife
was actually struggling from a severe illness.
So when he went into work, even when he was
guarding the containment chambers of truly
terrifying monsters like SCP-106, he was only
ever worrying about her.
Nobody else knew…
Except for SCP-999.
When the Tickle Monster sensed Dan’s distress,
he slithered over and began to climb on him,
unleashing his rays of anomalous good vibes.
Soon enough, Dan felt a kind of freedom he
hadn’t experienced since the beginning of
his wife’s illness.
Later that day, he felt the courage to visit
the Site-19 employee mental health counselor
at last, and became open about his emotional
struggles.
It began a long but worthwhile road to recovery,
all of which began with SCP-999.
And then, the Tickle Monster broke for lunch.
12:00 PM.
At around midday, every day, SCP-999 slithers
on over to the main Site-19 cafeteria to enjoy
a wholesome lunch with Foundation personnel
and some of the other friendly anomalies that
do lunch with them.
He’ll grab a bowl of ice cream and a colorful
jello pot from the friendly lunch lady, and
slither on over to the table where SCP-073,
Cain, and SCP-343, God, are sitting around,
chatting.
“No hard feelings about the whole, uh, mark
thing, right?”
God says, biting into his hamburger.
“It’s a process,” Cain replies.
Any awkwardness that was there before immediately
evaporated when SCP-999 entered the scene.
Both of these mysterious anomalies smiled
and began petting him as he cooed and trilled.
God levitated the spoon to feed 999 his ice
cream - Which Cain thought was a little show-offy
but held his tongue because he was lost in
the moment.
Cain helped 999 peel off the lid of his hello
pot with his precise, mechanical fingers.
Dr. Clef, who was eating a few tables cover,
also dropped in to give SCP-999 a playful
pat on the head.
And given that Dr. Clef typically has the
sensibility of an Xbox 360 Call of Duty lobby,
this show of vulnerability was an exceptional
act indeed.
Dr. Bright would have done the same, but he
was spending lunch in O5 Council detention
again because he did something really stupid
again.
What was it this time?
See if you can guess.
1:30 PM.
After lunch, SCP-999 would spend the next
half an hour having the nature of his father
- the terrifying Scarlet King - explained
to him.
For those privy to certain secret documents,
you’ll know that SCP-999 comes from the
most unlikely of parents: The interdimensional,
universe-destroying monarch of chaos and evil
known as the Scarlet King.
He was actually the progeny of the Scarlet
King’s seventh bride, whose son was prophesied
to one day defeat and dethrone the Scarlet
King - Not through violence and hatred, but
through a love and kindness so great it burns
out the Crimson Khan’s darkness.
Of course, he’s not ready to go toe to toe
with his estranged father just yet, nor would
the Foundation want him to.
They’ve made mistakes in the past by being
too gung-ho in prematurely weaponizing anomalies
under their care.
Just look at the absolute disaster that unfolded
when they tried to make Able part of a Mobile
Task Force, and he killed all his Foundation
comrades when they ran out of missions to
give him.
That’s why they’ve decided to take a very
different approach with SCP-999.
Rather than pushing him too hard, too early,
they’ve decided to start drip-feeding him
the knowledge, piece by piece, every day after
lunch.
Some of the more scholarly researchers have
been reading him choice extracts from Daevite
Scriptures concerning the Scarlet King.
They always follow it up with a little Rupert
the Bear, though, just so things don’t get
too intense.
2:00 PM.
After this unique SCP Foundation take on storytime
is done, SCP-999 is once again free to roam
around the site, dispensing joy to whoever
needs it most.
Something you need to understand about SCP-999
is that he’s utterly non-judgmental.
Even a beast of pure violence and hatred,
like SCP-682, is considered a potential friend
to 999.
You may even remember the time that 999 was
able to live up to his name and tickle the
Hard to Destroy Reptile into submission, inducing
a hysterical laughing fit in this otherwise
hardcore beastie.
That’s why 999 would sometimes stray into
the dark, spooky areas of the site that most
people would fear to tread if they weren’t
specifically assigned there.
For starters, he nestled up against the outside
of SCP-049, the Plague Doctor’s, cell.
The sinister surgeon was feeling a little
down in the dumps due to his continued failure
to stamp out the Pestilence, and the SCP Foundation’s
stubborn unwillingness to help him in that
task.
However, a loving visit from the Tickle Monster,
even on the other side of a plexiglass divider,
was enough to chase the blues away, just when
he needed the encouragement most.
This strengthened the Doctor’s resolve:
He would continue his research, no matter
how many lives it took to perfect his curative
method!
Admittedly, not the best result of an interaction
with SCP-999, but 999 was at least happy that
the peculiar beaked man seemed a little less
depressed now, at least - even if that lack
of depression may lead to a few further murders
down the line.
Who would be next on SCP-999’s rampage of
joyfulness and positive vibes?
SCP-999, like the benevolent Kaiju Gamera,
is a friend to all children, so he does what
he can to improve the quality of life for
anomalous children contained by the SCP Foundation.
As part of his daily rounds, he makes sure
to always visit SCP-053, the Young Girl, as
his positivity aura is too powerful for the
girl’s anomalous ability to passively cause
paranoia and violence to affect him.
She often reports having a wonderful time
during their sessions, though she wishes her
big dragon friend could come join in on their
tea parties, too.
4:00 PM.
By this time, SCP-999 is back to roaming again,
searching out people or anomalies he can land
a helping hand to.
Helping people, if you hadn’t somehow realized
it by now, is one of 999’s greatest joy
in life.
That’s why, when slithering near the high-security
humanoid containment wing and seeing groups
of researchers running for the hills, he got
the sense that perhaps he was needed here,
and decided to investigate further.
As all of the researchers ran, screaming,
in one direction, SCP-999 slithered audaciously
in the other.
He heard one of the researchers yelling, “The
Old Man got out!
Sound the alarm and run for your lives!”
Of course, this did nothing to deter SCP-999,
even as the containment breach sirens blasted
through the air around him.
999 didn’t fear death - he only feared failure.
Failure in the task to make everyone around
him as happy as possible, up to and including
some of the most horrific and depraved monsters
the SCP Foundation has ever contained, very
much including the monstrous creature coming
towards him down the hall.
The Old Man, SCP-106, gave a throaty chuckle
as he shuffled down the tiles, his black goo
fizzling on the ground.
With one hand, he traced his fingertips along
the wall with his fingertips, spreading corruption
that ate away at the wall like cancer.
With his other hand, he dragged a rapidly
melting corpse that had once been a hapless
researcher standing too close to the wall
of 106’s containment chamber.
Now, the Old Man was eager to cause more pain
and havoc in the rest of the facility before
he was forced back to containment.
Until he ran into SCP-999 coming towards him
in the hallway.
Suddenly, SCP-106 felt something change inside
his mind.
His typically sharp, predatory, sadistic thoughts
suddenly felt odd and fuzzy, almost formless.
It was almost like he’d been hit by some
kind of anomalous chloroform that dulled the
edge of his evil.
And then…
He was laughing.
Why?
Because this strange blobby creature had crawled
up onto his body and begun to tickle him relentlessly.
It didn’t make sense; how come this creature
wasn’t affected by his corrosive mucus!?
But it was already too late, he was doubled
over on the floor, cackling.
And unlucky for the Old Man, but luckily for
everyone else, it was enough to pacify him
until a Mobile Task Force with high-intensity
lights showed up and shepherded him back into
containment.
It was a truly humiliating defeat for SCP-106,
but, at the same time, he’d be churlish
to deny that he had somewhat of a good time…
7:00 PM.
As we get deeper into the evening, SCP-999
still has plenty to do.
After all, every day that ends at the SCP
Foundation also heralds the end of many people’s
lives - and that’s on a good day, too.
Needless to say, there would always be plenty
of people who needed cheering up at the end
of each day, and nobody was more up to the
task than the Tickle Monster.
First, SCP-999 decided to make its way down
to the Site-19 medical bay to treat everyone
who’d experienced varying degrees of horrific
injury from a typical day’s work at the
Foundation.
Some were horrifyingly burned.
Others were missing parts.
Some were pretty much catatonic with the mental
trauma of the things they’d seen.
Many had distinctive fresh wounds that could
have only come from SCP-682’s massive claws
and fangs.
It was a powerful wellspring of misery.
SCP-999 slithered from bed to bed, nuzzling
up to the different patients of the medical
bay and lifting their moods.
You’d be amazed at the medicinal benefits
of a positive mindset, and he’s one of the
few medical treatments that won’t utterly
destroy you if you don’t have insurance.
After helping the injured, SCP-999 decided
to visit the D-Class barracks.
While most of the SCP Foundation looked down
on the lowly D-Classes, especially given the
criminal history of many of them, but SCP-999
held no such prejudices.
He sensed that the people in the barracks
were confused and scared for their safety,
and that was enough for him to get in there
and help.
He slithered through the gangway, observing
that some of the bunk beds were empty from
the day’s less successful tests.
These hardened criminals, many of which were
literal murderers, immediately felt themselves
softening in the presence of this cheerful
blobby creature.
For the first time in many of their long,
difficult, and tragic lives, they dared to
believe that perhaps everything might be okay
again sometime in the not-so-distant future.
And SCP-999 couldn’t be happier about that.
9:30 PM.
As the night winds down, one of the researchers
assigned to SCP-999 reads him a bedtime story
to help him wind down after an exciting day.
SCP-999 tries not to go to bed too late at
night, knowing that an early bedtime and an
early rise ensure health and energy.
Whalesong and white noise is played over a
small radio while SCP-999 settles down to
sleep, ready to have only the sweetest dreams.
So ends another wonderful day.
And there you have it, folks, a day in the
life of the endlessly adorable SCP-999.
Is there anything from the Tickle Monster’s
daily routine that you think you might start
incorporating into your own day-to-day lives?
Let us know down in the comments.
Personally, in a world that can sometimes
be cold and cruel, we think having the strength
to be a little kinder, and smile a little
brighter, can make a far bigger difference
to some people than you’ll ever understand.
And nobody exemplifies that better than SCP-999.
Now go check out “SCP-999 Tickle Monster
VS.
the Most Evil SCPs” and “Children of SCP-001
The Scarlet King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?”
for more tales of this wholesome blobby boy!